ludovic emmanuelli président de wen jia
croissance pis expert des relations
entre l'afrique et l'europe monsieur
emmanuelli bienvenus bonjour merci
d'être avec nous alors première question
pourquoi les américains veulent réduire
leurs effectifs militaires en afrique
alors je me suis amusé j'ai rencontré du
monde parce que je savais que j'allais
venir vos voix j'ai vu dans un quartier
de la défense
quiconque leur dire si les états unis
parts d'afrique
à votre avis pour quelle raison
puisqu'ils n'ont plus aucun intérêt donc
finalement c'était peut-être une bonne
réponse est-ce que l'intérêt pour les
états unis de laisser des troupes d'une
manière financière est intéressant
visiblement non par contre il ya
peut-être d'autres obligations qu'il
devrait mettre en oeuvre donc c'était
utopique de croire qu'ils y étaient pour
sécuriser la zone en tout cas le
continent africain
alors au début peut-être parce qu'ils
ont quand même monté une agence sise en
agence qui s'appelle la des fc qui a été
revalorisé enfin qui a été recréée à la
suite d'une agence qui s'appelle au pic
en octobre dernier pour pouvoir
justement développer du business avec
l'afrique
mais visiblement les militaires pour eux
en afrique les militaires américains
n'ont pas forcément un intérêt de retour
sur investissement alors on l'a vu en
cette annonce des américains en quête
vraiment emmanuel macron pourquoi
écouter la france c'est environ 4500
personnes plus et 200 et quelques qui
vont aller en afrique pour aider
justement ces pays acp a stoppé le
djihadisme des états unis s'est quand
même quasiment le double c'est 9000
personnes 9000 personnes plus au niger
vous avez une base de drones qui
s'occupe de faire de rance du
renseignement et s'ils partent ça va
être difficile
alors on a les chinois en ethiopie les
rues sans les militaires russes
déployées en centrafrique
les états unis ne l'est-il pas le champ
libre aux autres en partant du continent
africain alors d'abord je pense qu'il
faut revenir sur 30 trempe des élections
prochainement trump avait dit qu'il
allait se quitter le
quitter l'afrique quitté moyen-orient il
est en train de le faire parce qu'il a
des élections prochainement
le fait de dire qui va repositionner ses
armées face à la chine
et face à la russie me semble tout à
fait légitime pour le peuple américain
mais qui
comment peut-on penser que les chinois
les américains les russes vont se taper
dessus on a des gens qui sont
intelligents qui vont jamais se prendre
à ce genre de jeu
alors cette annonce avait été faite au
moment où la france a réuni les
dirigeants du g5 sahel pour resserrer un
peu le front antiterroriste est ce que
il s'agit là d'un hasard de calendrier
avec trump est ce qu'on peut parler de
hasard de calendrier il a agi de la
sorte il va certainement y avoir des
négociations pour qu' il puisse rester
ou revenir
il faut savoir que les les états unis
ont quand même des intérêts économiques
importants mais où l'armée n'est
peut-être pas n'importe pas forcément le
confort nécessaire mais ils ont des
quand même beaucoup d'intérêt économique
il voudrait concurrencer les chinois
sachant que les russes sont en embuscade
et que les russes ont fait pas mal de
choses au niveau de l'armement donc les
américains et l'armement aussi ça peut
les intéresser
mais pour le moment j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu le jeu
le chat et de la souris avec les
élections américaines en orbite très
rapidement qu'avez vous pensé des
conclusions du sommet de pau le
renforcement de la coopération militaire
entre les pays du g5 ça l est de la
france va écouter les africains
malheureusement ou un problème c'est le
terrorisme les français ont
malheureusement un autre problème c'est
le terrorisme plus on peut associer des
communautés de gens qui sont contre a
même agresseur puis il faut le faire
c'est pour ça que les américains
devraient rester avec nous et avec
toutes les forces en présence pour
lutter contre le terrorisme qui peut
ensuite comme une marée d'équinoxe
débouler sur les continents et sur
d'autres pays ludovic emmanueli merci
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes président de l ong croissance
peas et expert des relations entre
l'afrique et l'europe participent merci